in niederbayerischen passau gibt es
ärger um diese 42 meter lange stützmauer
vor mehr als 50 jahren wird sie von der
kommune gebaut damit die straße davor
tiefer gelegt werden kann
jetzt muss das bröselige bauwerk saniert
werden und zahlen soll die reparaturen
nicht etwa die stadt sondern franz mit
ihm gehört das grundstück dahinter herr
mick ist fassungslos gstaad versuch
kosten auf uns abzuwälzen
für martin mir gebaut haben also dass
mir die sanierungskosten tragen sind
das widerspricht völlig meinem
rechtsverständnis vor mehr als einem
halben jahrhundert wird die alte straße
vor dem elternhaus von franz mit tiefer
gelegt die gemeinde grubweg die heute zu
passau gehört muss dafür die stützmauer
bauen mein vater hat immer gesagt die
mauer geht uns nichts anderes gehört die
gehört der stadt passau die stadt sieht
das jedoch ganz anders
sie teilt franz brück schriftlich mit
laut grundbuch steht die mauer auf
seinem grund und boden deshalb sei er
verantwortlich
es ist für die frage des eigentums also
unerheblich wer die mauer errichtet hat
und welchen zweck die mauer hat aha die
kommune baut auf mix privatem grund und
er muss sich jetzt um das bauwerk
kümmern
absurd denn für ihn hat das teure folgen
er soll für die sanierung zahlen
mindestens 25.000 euro obwohl einzig die
stadt von der stützmauer profitiert es
ist viel befahrene straße und der
verkehr der wer ohne diese stützmauer
wahrscheinlich so wie es jetzt ist gar
nicht möglich eine schweinerei weil ich
kann ja nicht einfach jetzt ein
günstiges eigentümer der für die mal gar
nichts dafür kann das jetzt
aufgetretenen totale unverschämtheit
total unverschämt uns aber unseriös
im passauer rathaus will sich zu dem
fall niemand vor der kamera äußern
hier versteckt man sich hinter
paragrafen schriftlich heißt es nach
jetzigem kenntnisstand liegt die besagte
mauer auf dem grundstück des privaten
eigentümers wenn der eigentümer in
irgendeiner weise einen anderen
sachverhalt belegen kann ist die stadt
passau selbstverständlich bereit diesen
zu prüfen
für franz mück und viele passauer
versucht sich die stadt so aus der
verantwortung
stehlen ich fühle mich total
verschaukelt für macht dass sie für maut
sollen soll die volleyball habe ich
finde es eigentlich unverschämt von der
stadt pasta da ist jetzt die ganzen
kosten haufen hiermit übertragen werden
franz mit wird gegen die stadt klagen am
ende wird wohl ein gericht entscheiden
müssen ob er wirklich für eine mauer
zahlen muss die die stadt gebaut hat